Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricardo Lops, and
today I'm joined by a return guest, Dr. Omar
Bartov, Dean's Professor of Holocaust and Genocide studies at
Brown University, and today we're going to talk about
his latest book, Israel What Went Wrong. So Dr.
Bartov, welcome back to the show. It's always a
big pleasure to everyone.
Thanks for having me here again.
Uh, OK, so one of the things I would
like to focus on today and you also explore
in your book is, uh, Zionism. So what is,
uh, Zionism or what was it originally? BECAUSE then
we can get into how it might have changed
over time and some misconceptions that people have about
it.
So Zionism is a movement that began in the
late 19th century and it was influenced by many
other national movements of that period. It's a movement
that assumed that the, the Jewish people, which had
existed in one form or another in Europe and
in the Middle East and other parts of the
world for A couple of millennia was a nation
or that could be made into a nation. Most
of the Jews of the world at that time,
about 80% of the Jews in the entire world,
were living in East Central Europe, and they were
coming under increasing pressure because of the growth of
ethno-nationalism around them, one of whose attributes was also
the growth of anti-Semitism. And so what Zionism proposed
was that the Jews, like all other groups, form
themselves into a nation, claim self-determination as a nation,
and then find a place in which they could
then implement that idea and create a state or
some kind of political entity for themselves. And the
territory that Zionism proposed would be where the Jews
would create their own state was the ancestral homeland,
mythical, historical, of the Jews in what was then
Palestine, which at the time in the late 19th
century was part of the Ottoman Empire. And as
of the early 1880s, small numbers of Jews who
increasingly refer to themselves as Zionists start coming to
the Ottoman Empire to settle, not as religious Jews,
but as the carriers of a new national movement
called Zionism. So that's the beginning of Zionism at
the time. It was certainly not the most popular
movement among Jews. Most Jews who were coming under
increasing pressure and violence in Russia, in Ukraine, in
Eastern Europe, uh, and also were deeply impoverished, uh,
made other decisions. That is, about 2.5 million Jews
left East Central Europe and went to North America
between the early 1880s and World War I. But
increasingly as it becomes more difficult for Jews to
migrate, the United States closes off its borders after
World War I, and in Europe there is growing
resentment against immigrants, especially with the economic crisis. As
a result of that, Zionism becomes more popular, as
well as the growth of political anti-Semitism that appears
to be increasingly threatening for Jews in Europe. And
so Zionism from the end of World War I
to the outbreak of World War II becomes a
much more popular movement and brings several hundreds of
thousands of Jews from Europe, mostly from East Central
Europe, to Palestine.
When was it that Israel's independence or the formation
of the state of Israel became intertwined with Palestinian
displacement or the displacement of Palestinian people?
So one part of this process that I described
is that when Jews start coming to Palestine, uh,
which becomes, uh, comes to be called Palestine under
the British Mandate after World War One and becomes
under the British, the so-called mandate, which is uh
permission that the uh that Britain gets from. THE
international community to rule over Palestine and cause it
that once Jews start coming there, even before World
War I, this begins to create a conflict between
the indigenous population, Arabs living there who are increasingly
referred to as Palestinians or speak of themselves as
Palestinians, and these new immigrants from the point of
view. Of the Palestinians, as the numbers of Jews
grow, the way they experience it is that they
are experiencing settler colonialism, that people are coming from
Europe and settling the land and encroaching on their
own lands and claiming that that's their territory. So
the friction between Jews coming to Palestine who believe
that they're coming home to their ancestral homeland. And
Palestinians who live there who say, well, that's where
we live, and you're taking over our land begins
from the very beginning. And it's interesting because there
were Jews living there before, but the Jews living
in Palestine before that were living there as, as,
as local communities and were not making national claims.
They were, they were Ottoman citizens, and they were
part of the society there. The conflict grows as
the numbers of Jews grow, and Jewish settlement in
Palestine in the 1920s and 1930s is supported by
the British. The British in 1917 issued the Balfour
Declaration. Which promises that Britain, then the largest empire
in the world, would facilitate the creation of a
Jewish national home in Palestine. They don't exactly explain
what a Jewish national home is. It's kind of
open to interpretation, but eventually it becomes the idea
of creating a Jewish state, and they helped the
Jews create the infrastructure for a future state in
Palestine in the 1920s and the early 1930s. So
that creates more and more friction between Jews and
Palestinians. Uh, THAT comes to a head, of course,
eventually in 1948, because in 1947, The British after
World War II declared that they no longer want
to be the mandatory power in Palestine. They don't
have the energy. They don't have the manpower, resources.
They're exhausted after World War II. They're fed up
with all the friction in Palestine. They want to
leave and they hand over Palestine to the UN,
the newly established UN, and the United Nations offers
a partition resolution. Uh, uh, United Nations on, on
November 29th, 1947, uh, decides that Palestine will be
divided into two states, a Jewish state and an
Arab state. The leadership of the Jewish community, which
numbers then about 600,000 people, accepts that petition. It
it accepts it reluctantly because it thinks that it's
being offered too little. It's being offered just over
half of the territory of Palestine. And the leadership
of the Palestinians and the Arab states surrounding Palestine
reject it because they say it's unfair because 2/3
of the population of Palestine are Palestinians and they're
being offered less than half of Palestine. And that
leads to the creation of a Jewish state, not
a Palestinian state, and to a war that breaks
out in 1948. In the course of that war,
The Israeli military, which is being established and then
becomes the so-called Israel Defense Forces, the IDF, ethnically
cleanses most of the Palestinians in that territory. And
so by the end of that war with the
ceasefire agreements of 1949, A state of Israel is
created in which the majority of the population are
Jews and the majority of the Palestinians who had
lived there become refugees.
Do you think it's fair to say that over
time Zionism has evolved into what is now an
ethno-nationalist and settler colonialist ideology? Do you think that's
a fair characterization?
So first of all, Zionism was always an ethno-national
movement. It's it didn't evolve into an ethno-national movement.
It was an ethno-national movement, that is, it was
a movement that claimed that a particular ethnos, Jews,
are a nation, and according to the logic of
that, such nations deserve a place of their own.
This was not a Jewish invention. This was all
around. That's what the polls said, Ukrainians, Latvia, Estonians,
whoever. Germans, this was a European invention and and
the Jews latched on to that partly because they
were victims of this process as a minority in
all the countries in which they lived. When you
create an ethno-national state, one instinct is that you
identify. The people who do not belong to your
ethnos but who live in that state as outsiders
to your state as a minority. That's how minorities
were invented. They were invented by the creation of
ethno-national states. Before that they were not minorities. They
were just different groups living in a particular territory.
So it's always been that. But until 1948, and
as I write in the book, Zionism has two
faces. One face is of an ethno-national movement that
claims a particular territory and exercises precisely that sort
of dynamic of saying this is our land, we
want to be a majority here. The other people
who live here should be a minority, although in
fact they are a majority. And there needs to
be some mechanism as to how do we make
ourselves into a majority. The The plan the Zionists
have is that more and more Jews would come
from Europe until Palestine becomes a Jewish majority state.
But in the Holocaust, most of the Jews of
Europe are murdered, and so those people who were
expected to create a Jewish majority state are no
longer there to make that possible, and that is
the sort of underlying logic of the ethnic cleansing
of Palestinians. That's the other mechanism. Again, it, it
wasn't invented only by Zionism. Ethnic cleansing has been
carried out by many other national ethno-national movements, but
in this case, it's the Zionists who carried it
out in 1948. After the establishment of the state,
this one phase of Zionism, which is to say
we are here to provide a safe haven for
the Jews of Europe. And in many ways that's
true. In the 1920s and 1930s when hundreds of
thousands of Jews come to Europe, that's how they're
saved. Those Jews who stayed in Europe were largely
murdered. That includes my own family, both, both my,
my grandparents who came in the 1920s and 1930s
to Palestine. The rest of their families, my families
whom I never knew, were all murdered because they
stayed in Poland. So that argument of Zionism seems
logical, but Zionism has another face, and that face
is from the point of view of Palestinians of
settler colonialism, that is, those people who come, including
my grandparents, functionally act as settler colonial encroachers on
Palestinian land. In 1948, when the state is established,
and that's my argument in the book, the state
has a choice to make. It promises. Uh, IN
its declaration, in its proclamation of a state, it
promises to be a, a, an equal state for
all its citizens. That all those Jews and Arabs,
men and women, all those who become citizens of
the state will have equal rights. Now he does
that because the UN demands that in order to
recognize it as a state. It also promises to
issue a constitution. That would reflect the spirit of
that proclamation of the state, and it's supposed to
do that within a few months. The proclamation of
the state is in May 1948, and it says
by October 1st, 1948, we'll issue a constitution, and
we are still waiting for that constitution. A constitution
was never issued by the state, was never adopted
by the state, and so the state never actually
enshrines in law a commitment to equal rights to
all its citizens and never determines in any document
what its final borders are. It only has ceasefire
lines. It doesn't have any borders that it recognizes
as the final borders. And that decision not to
have a constitution means that Zionism becomes at that
point a state ideology, because now there's a state,
and the only thing that drives it is Zionist
ideology. Right,
when nowadays people identify themselves as anti-Zionist and they
say that they are anti-Zionist because they oppose the
settler colonialist actions performed by the state of Israel,
and they oppose ethnic cleansing of the Palestinian people.
Recent genocide, the expansionist activities of Israel, and they
oppose, for example, what they call a two-tier legal
system in Israel where people that are descendants of
Palestinians or Palestinian prisoners are treated differently than Jewish
citizens, for example, and so So I mean what
they are opposing is all of those kinds of
actions, and they label themselves as anti-Zionist. Do you
think that that is a proper label for them
to have that what they are opposing is really
Zionism? And if so, do you think that Zionism
can be the same as anti-Semitism in any way,
or no?
Uh, OK, that's, that's a big question. So as
you can understand from my previous answer, um, I
think that Zionism historically is a movement that you
can support or not support, you can like or
not like. Um, I personally am, I am not
a great supporter of any nationalism of any kind
because nationalism has brought about a huge amount of
destruction to human lives, to cultures. Around the world,
uh, but it is what it is. It's something
that happens, so to say I'm opposed to that
is, is well and fine, but I don't know
exactly what it means. We live today in a
world of nations. Try living outside of a nation
in this world. Think of migrants. If you don't
have a passport, if you don't have citizenship, then
you are a ship adrift the ocean. You have
nothing, uh, and so it's, it's easy to say,
well, I'm against it, but what is your alternative?
Uh, SO in that term to say I'm an
anti-Zionist, you can say I'm anti-Portugal, I'm anti-Spain, I'm
anti-France, it's, it's, it's a meaningless term, uh, and
I find that to be a kind of cheap
label that people now stick on their sleeve because
it's sort of become. Um, POPULAR to say that.
On the other hand, Zionism as it has evolved
and as it exists today as the state ideology
of Israel is completely insupportable for all the reasons
that you mention. It has become a violent racist,
Jewish supremacist, ethnic cleansing, genocidal movement. It's an ideology
and it's an that ideology of Zionism in many
ways like other ideologies, you know, uh, Portugal had
a dictatorship, uh, Italy had fascism, Nazi Germany had
Nazism. With the fall of the dictatorship in Portugal,
no one said, let's break up Portugal. It doesn't
have a right to exist, but the dictatorship didn't
have a right to exist and was thankfully done
away with after many decades. In Italy, no one
said Italy should just go away to the dung
heap of history. They said fascism should. And so
in that sense, Zionism today has no viability. Anyone
who today proclaims their loyalty to Zionism must admit
that they are supporting an ideology that has supported
genocide. And if you support an ideology that supports
genocide, well, you have to look at yourself in
the mirror and say, is this something that I
can support? Does that mean that Israel can continue
to exist as a state? I think Israel will
continue to exist as a state. It's not going
anywhere. Just like the Palestinians are not going anywhere
despite all the claims by Israeli politicians and ideologues
that they have to go, that they don't belong,
all that kind of nonsense, but it has to
redefine itself, as many countries in the 20th century
did when they rid themselves of these ideologies. And
in the case of Israel, in order to redefine
itself, it has to go back to the beginning.
It has to go back to precisely that moment
of 1948. It has to give itself a constitution.
It has to define its borders. It has to
accept the wrongs that it committed in 1948 all
the way to Gaza, and in many ways Gaza
is an extension of what happened in 1948. It's
a second attempt to ethnically cleanse the Palestinians. People
in Israel spoke about it as being the second
Nakba, the second catastrophe for Palestinians. They spoke about
it in positive terms. That's what we want to
do to them. It has to go back to
that and rethink how that territory, which is now
one state. There are no two states there. It's
one state between the Jordan and the sea. How
does that state redefine itself as a place where
the equal numbers of 7 million Jews and 7
million Palestinians can share that space, and dreams of
getting rid of one group or the other are
genocidal, whether they come from the left or the
right, whether they come from Palestinians or Jews. They're
not the only humane. ACCEPTABLE resolution of this to
my mind is to find a way for those
people who live there to share the space rather
than to dream about kicking them out.
What is it like to grow up in Israel,
serving the IDF, for example, and be exposed to
these state and settler colonialist ideology? I mean, what,
what kinds of ideas in terms of what might
be Islamophobic ideas, anti-Palestinian ideas? Ideas and ideas that
perhaps drive people, Jewish people from Israel to support
ethnic cleansing, genocide, wars of aggression. I mean, what
is it like to be exposed to all of
those kinds of ideas and what effects does it
have on people according to your own experience?
Look, I'm, I'm, I'm 72, so my experience is
very different from the experience of younger cos of
Israelis. When I was born and raised, uh, Israel
was a very small state, uh, that was before
1967, um, and, um, the discourse of, uh, about
the nature of the state. And the reality of
living in Israel were very, very different from that
of later generations. My, my eldest son is now
almost 40 years old. He has no idea. What
pre-1967 Israel was like. So for later generations, even
the notion of the so-called green line, that is,
which was the ceasefire line of 1949, which defined
the borders of Israel between 1949 and 1967. They
have no clue what that is. The, the idea
that Israel was once a country between 1948 and
1967, where the majority of people were actually Jews,
only 20% of the population were Palestinians, they don't
know about that. They, they, they've never lived in
a country that is not an occupying country. So,
uh, if you ask about my experience, my own
experience was very different, and in some ways, that's
why. It is difficult for me and I think
for many people of my generation in Israel, especially
those who grew up in left-leaning homes, who grew
up in secular homes, who grew up in homes
where there were ideals of social justice and national
justice, to look at Israel today and to recognize
it. It feels like a completely foreign country. Uh,
NOW that does not mean that I did not
imbibe, uh, in my childhood and in school, a
particular Zionist ideology. I should say that, you know,
thinking about it, uh, when I was growing up,
we never thought about ourselves as Zionists. We didn't
even think of ourselves as Jews. We were Israelis.
Zionism was a kind of term that was used
by the old people who made all these big
speeches that we found really boring. We were just
born there and we thought it was our place,
and it took a long time for us, because
of our education, for people of my generation to
start recognizing. That, you know, I was born in
the mid-1950s, less than 10 years after the expulsions
of the expulsion of the Palestinians, to realize that
we grew up in a country in which there
were very few Arabs because they had been kicked
out. No one spoke about it at the time.
There were empty villages and nobody said how were
they emptied? What happened there? So yes, for members
of my generation, it took a long time and
many never went through that process of recognizing that
the state was established on a major act of
injustice, that it was born in sin. It's not,
again, it's not the only country that was born
in sin, but that's a particular sin of that
particular country. For younger generations, this is a very
different situation that we're seeing today. Israel has become
Uh, much more religious than he was when I
was growing up there, including the army, is much
more religious, and the religion that people have now
has almost nothing to do with the kind of
religion that my grandparents believed in, the kind of
traditional Judaism that they had, and they were both
Orthodox Jews, both, both sides of my family. Now
it's a messianic Jewish supremacist, anti-democratic, violent type of
Jewish religion that no Jew around the world living
outside of Israel could ever endorse. Uh, AND so,
um, the, the, the way that Israelis think of
themselves today is very, very different, and I'll say
one last important thing, you know, when I was,
I left Israel in 1989, uh, and I had
served in the military, both as a regular soldier
and then as a reservist, and I did serve
in occupied territories, but these were the very early
years of the occupation. The formative experience of generations
of Israelis has been to act as occupiers, as
colonizers, and that has really changed the mentality of
society vis a vis Palestinians. It has created the
process of dehumanization of Palestinians, of thinking of them
as people who should be bossed around, who don't
have rights, who shouldn't have rights, who don't even
have the right to have rights. Uh, AND so
that sort of long-term process, uh, is in many
ways the result of the long-term occupation that Israel
has exercised for most of its existence.
How do you look at groups like Hamas and
Hezbollah? I mean, in the, in the way that
they behave toward the state of Israel, do you
agree with, uh, I mean, the label of them
being terrorist groups, or do you look at them
as more of resistance movements?
Well, look, first of all, uh, Hamas and, and
Hezbollah are very different. Um, um, SO if, if
you focus on, on, on Hamas for a moment,
uh, Hamas is a, an Islamic fundamentalist movement and
ideology. In many ways, ironically, it has much in
common in its ideology and in its sort of
long range goals with Jewish extremists who happen to
be now in the Israeli government, people like Smotric,
that is it, it wants ultimately, and it doesn't,
you know, deny that to create an Islamic state
in all of Palestine. A religious Islamic state in
which there might be some tolerance for other minority
religions, and people like Spotori want to create a
Jewish religious state in the same territory in which
there would be as few Christians and Muslims as
possible, so that kind of ideology is very far
from what I think I could support. Whether it
comes from the from the Jewish right or from
Hamas, but of course Hamas is a creature of
circumstances. We have to remember that Hamas really emerged
in the 1980s because of Israeli rule over Gaza.
In Gaza, there was resistance at the time, mostly
by Fatah, which was the armed wing of the
PLO of the Palestinian Liberation Organization, which was secular
at the time, was Marxist, adored Che Guevara, and
so forth. This was the kind of symbolism of
the time, and the Israeli occupiers, particularly one general,
Sharon, who later became chief. Minister of Defense and
then became prime minister claimed that the best way
to have a counterweight to Fatah was to work
with Hamas, with what became Hamas, with members of
the, of the Muslim Brotherhood, because they just took
care of the education, of welfare for the Palestinians
there. They were not particularly militant. Well, of course
they did become militant. And they became militant because
of Israeli policies, so they are a creature of
Israeli occupation and in many ways, of course, Hezbollah
is the same thing. There was no Hezbollah before
1982. In 1982, Israel invaded southern Lebanon, took over
the southern part of Lebanon which is populated by
Shiites. And that the resistance to Israeli occupation of
southern Lebanon, of the Shiite part of Lebanon, produced
Hezbollah, which is a Shiite resistance resistance group supported
of course by Iran. I don't think that either
group is particularly good. Uh, FOR its own people,
I don't think that if I were Lebanese, I,
I, I wouldn't be in a mood of Hezbollah,
and I know many Palestinians who don't really love
Hamas. If you're a woman living in Gaza, you,
and, and you're not an Islamic fundamentalist, I don't
think that's the kind of movement you would choose,
um, because of its own ideology. But I don't
think that simply speaking about them as terrorist organizations
explains anything to you. They use terrorist means. Certainly
Hamas has in the past. If you call suicide
bombers, people blowing themselves up in cafes, and discotheques,
in restaurants. You can call it terrorism or not,
but it's certainly a very violent way of resisting
occupation. But what they are about is resisting occupation.
You cannot undo. The ideology of Hamas through bombs.
You can kill a lot of people, but you
cannot undo that. You cannot change people's minds through
that. So from my point of view, while I
don't think that Hamas is the is is the
best solution for Palestinians, I think that for Israel,
if it wants a peaceful resolution of that, it
has to provide hope for Palestinians. It has to
provide a different political horizon for them. And then
I think fewer people will opt for more radical
solutions such as those that are being proposed by
Hamas, and fewer people in Israel would support the
kind of ethno-nationalist Jewish supremacists that are now in
the Israeli government.
Looking at the, I think we could argue, is
still the ongoing genocide in Gaza, the continuous takeover
of the West Bank, and also the situation, the
current situation in southern Lebanon. What do you think
could be the aftermath of all of that? I
mean, what could we expect from all of these
actions by the state of Israel?
Well, look, you may know that a couple of
days ago, um, I published an op ed in
the, in the New York Times that actually tries
to think about that. About what I call the
future of genocide. And right now the future of
genocide looks very bright, that is that Israel, along
with its allies, has possibly created a new idea
about genocide, that genocide could be accepted by certain
states as the extension of policy by other means,
because not only Is Israel not being brought to
account for what it did and not only its
allies in Europe and certainly the United States not
recognizing their complicity in what happened, everybody seems to
be Thinking about gainful prospects from this process, that
is that if we think about what is the
future of Gaza, if the future of Gaza is
to create the beautiful Riviera which would be built
by Palestinians and served by Palestinians who would be
kept in camps in Gaza, then, and all this
built with potentially with money from the Gulf states
and Saudi Arabia. Then everybody would profit. Israel, Arab
states, European states, real estate moguls, and the victims
of this process who began as the victims of
genocide will continue being victimized. That's a very scary
prospect. It's not only for Palestinians, it's a scary
prospect for the entire international order because it means
that Many other states could say, well, you know,
we can carry out genocide, we can rope in
a lot of people and reap a lot of
profits. It's actually not a bad way to pursue
politics. Uh, NOW that's of course a very dire
prediction, and I'm not sure that it will happen.
I hope it won't. I just wanted to warn
that this may be the future. There is, uh,
uh, another way of looking at this. And the
other way of looking at this is for European
states and for the United States to realize that
this will dismantle the international order and that in
order to rectify that one has to put immense
pressure on Israel. Which means, and I think that's
not impossible, that a future American administration and European
governments, which are very timid but may adjust to
new American politics, will decide on a regime of
sanctions against the state of Israel. BY and will
redress the question of where does, where are the
limits of power of Israel determined. If the limits
of power of Israel are determined in Washington, then
it's limitless. If it's returned to Jerusalem, then Israel
will be forced to go back to politics. But
that would mean a regime of military, economic, and
political sanctions on Israel, which would eventually bring about
a redefinition of the state itself. You mentioned all
kinds of things earlier about the kind of two-tier
system in Israel. That two-tier system is called apartheid.
What exists in Israel today in the West Bank
is apartheid. That apartheid is creeping into the state
of Israel, and you may know that just a
couple of days ago, one of the Supreme Court
justices in Israel claimed that anyone who uses the
term apartheid in Israel has no room to live
in Israel, has no room to act in Israel.
So the Supreme Court. Of the state of Israel,
which was being supported by all these protesters on
the eve of October 7th because of the attempt
by the state to change the rules of the
game, that very Supreme Court, which had established the
apartheid regime now forbids even using the term in
Israel. That will not change from within. If the
Supreme Court is moved over to the dark side,
things are not going to change from within. They
will change from without, and that calls for international
will. That international will will not come just because
of goodwill, but it will come because of a
definition of national interests, and I think that that
may happen with the new administration in the US.
So that's the other option. That's the other future
of preventing a state like Israel from benefiting from
genocide. Right now, the odds are 50/50, I would
say.
So I have one last question then. ER earlier
in my previous question I also mentioned er the
situation in southern Lebanon. I mean, why is it
that apparently Israel is in a state of forever
war with its neighbor with its neighbors and we
also have of course the war, the ongoing war
in Iran. And do you think that this sort
of relationship, warring relationship with its with its neighbors
can never lead to any form of stability for
Israel and even the broader Middle East region?
So look, I mean, I think there are two
answers to this. There's a sort of short term
and a much deeper response. The short term is
that for the current government, for the current prime
minister in Israel, for Benjamin Netanyahu, war is the
only way to survive. So he needs a war
to keep going on, and he's inciting it just
like you mentioned the war in Iran. It was
clearly we know now Netanyahu, who had tried to
persuade many other American presidents to join Israel in
a war against Iran, finally found the useful idiot
in the, in the White House to, to, to
do that for him, and we see the consequences
of that, as many people have said before, it
cannot succeed. And it was a very bad policy
choice for the United States, but for Netanyahu, it's
fantastic. He needs war to continue because he's like
this cartoon character floating over the abyss. As long
as he doesn't look down, he doesn't fall. And
he needs the war because if the war ends,
then, well, there will be a commission of inquiry
about what happened on October 7th, of which of
course he was the main culprit and everything that
happened after that. He is under trials of corruption
and so forth as long as there's a state
of emergency, which he may invoke again on the
eve of the elections in Israel in October just
to prevent or to modify the elections in ways
that would serve him. So that's the sort of
one sort of immediate cause, but the larger cause,
of course, is much deeper than that. The larger
cause is that although Israel for lengthier or shorter
periods did have some periods of peace in between,
has always been engaged in conflict and in war.
Why is that? It's because Israel has refused to
face up to the main question of its existence,
and the main question of its existence is, can
it be a Jewish and democratic state? It cannot
be a Jewish and democratic state as long as
it is not purely Jewish. And it cannot be
purely Jewish as long as he wants to rule
over large territories in which there are large numbers
of Palestinians. So it has to resolve the fundamental
question of its existence, relations between Jews and Palestinians.
It has refused to do that since 1948. It
still refuses to do that. And as we know,
In 2002, Saudi Arabia already offered a peace plan
for Israel and the rest of the Arab world,
and Israel has ignored it since 2002. Why? Because
their plan called for a resolution of the so-called
conflict, meaning really the occupation of Palestinians by Israel.
That's the core reason for the ongoing violence between
Israel and its neighbors.
Right, but, but I mean, just to reemphasize the
second part of my question, do you think that
this kind of attitude of Israel toward its neighbors
in the Middle Eastern region can ever lead, I,
I mean, of course, if it stays on this
trajectory of continuous war, can it ever lead to
stability in the region?
No, look, I mean, but obviously war is instability,
so as long as you have war, you have
instability. STABILITY comes when you stop war. I, the
fact of the matter is, and, and people get
confused about that. Israel has peace with Jordan. Israel
has peace with Egypt. Israel had very good relations
that were formed over the last 10 years or
so with the Gulf states. Saudi Arabia wants peace
with Israel. That is, Lebanon wants peace with Israel.
Syria has a regime now that wants some kind
of peace with Israel. So the neighborhood actually wants
has come to the point. It wasn't always the
case, one has to admit, but it has come
to the point that the neighborhood would like to
integrate Israel into its own neighborhood. And that would
serve their interests, not for love of Zionism or
Jews, but because Israel has shown itself to be
a resilient country and is supported by very powerful
allies, so it's good for everyone. Israel has refused
to do that. And it's refused to do it
again because of course it would like to have
peace with Saudi Arabia. It would like to have
peace with the Gulf states, yes, but it refuses
to face up to the fact that in the
borders in which it controls, half of the people
don't have equal rights, and they are struggling to
gain those rights, and they're appealing. To our populations
around the world, in countries which are mostly authoritarian
and which worry about the popular sentiment in the
countries that they rule, the Palestinians are appealing to
those people to come to their rescue. That creates
this ongoing instability. So if you want to get
to the core of the issue, you have to
go back to that beginning. If you go back
there, if you, uh, I would say compel Israel
for its own good. To find a way to
share that space with Palestinians that will resolve the
issue of conflict between Israel, not so much with
its neighbors because it's not fighting other Arab countries.
The last war Israel fought with Arab armies was
in 1973. That's the war that I was in.
But the militants who are fighting against the Israeli
occupation of their own lands.
OK, great. So let's wrap up the interview here
then, Dr. Bartov, and the book is again Israel
What Went Wrong, and I will be leaving a
link to it in the description of the interview.
And Dr. Bartov, thank you again for taking the
time to come on the show. It's always a
big pleasure to talk with you.
Thank you. Thanks for having me.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights, Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at lights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Mulleran, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingberrd, Arnaud Wolf, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forrest Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegerru Inai Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andre, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoo, and
Hal Herzognon, Michel Jonathan Labrarith, John Yardston, and Samuel
Cerri, Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel, Sardusran,
David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezara Romain Roach, Diego Londono
Correa. Yannik Punteran Ruzmani, Charlotte Blis, Nicole Barbaro, Adam
Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alec Baka Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov,
Zal Adrian Yei Poltontin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward
Hall, Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolotti, Gabriel P
Scortez or Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffyani Smith,
and Wisman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg Jarno,
Luke Lovai, Georgios Theophannus, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin, David
Williams, Dio Costa, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex Shaw,
Marie Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D. Lee
Junior. Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber, Robert
Grassy, Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix, Mark
Kempel, Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly Johnson,
Benjamin Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael
Bensleyman. George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate Van
Goler, Alexander Obert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali Mohammadi,
Perpendicular, Jannes Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David Pinsov,
Sean Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A special
thanks to my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank Lucas
Stink, Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller, Thomas
Trumbull, Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlomon Negro, Al
Nick Cortiz, and Nick Golden, and to my executive
producers, Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and Rosie.
Thank you for all.